pocket 3 - the defensive a deep 3 yes
Nick nurse is still allowing Dame to go
one-on-one right now because he's just
making stuff happen or these feel
doesn't make it in the East Wow look at
that range from Damian Lillard comprised
this is who he is
you're big on the Brawn in that
situation you got to be up because
there's a price to pay that's beautiful
office that's a 30-footer
it's control glasses Egyptian president
[Applause]
often speech like this is a regular for
him do you hear how much Terry Stotts is
yelling run
Dave will write into a bona 35-footer
his Oklahoma City and the getaway to
that four-game trip where was that one
from Lombardi bus
logo
[Applause]
what are you thinking right now
that's what I'm thinking - so it just
shocks me now at this point
that defenses are not prepared for it or
I get it's totally unnatural for
somebody to be super come that far
[Applause]
blazars have tied this game at 99
three-point shot and once it gets into
Dame's hands
he's throwing buddy
[Applause]
today's yeah two defenders at wide open
[Applause]
after the great pastor CJ came in off
that line quite a bit shot clock at
three that's the defense look at this
job here shot clock running down from
the a in motor coming up the American
Express halftime report what three
[Applause]
one dribble one dribble over half-court
and I raise
he wasn't been toured and when they
wouldn't shut it so look at that man oh
man that was a beauty
[ __ ]
[Applause]
blazars need that one oh my god thing of
beauty greater the hands work yeah
regular extension and everything what
happened to boy Adam left coach you like
that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report